pas tant parce que moi je suis très
mauvais donc ils sont vraiment majeurs
met en mode sport wear de le ramener
ok d'accord
salut ceinture aujourd'hui au programme
on va tester le drone de parrot le
hanafi mais avant toute chose je vous
montre un taux que j'étais récupérer
quelques instants et là j'ai récupéré un
nouveau produit testé c'est le minix
deux aces de chez sony on produit qui en
tout cas a l'air plutôt cool j'ai testé
le mx2 à barcelone au mwc n'y a pas très
longtemps la semine x 2 aces a l'air
d'être super cool
et puis rester connecté parce que vous
allez voir on à paris vachement de
shiomi il ya plein de nouveaux produits
qui arrivent alors j'ai testé dans pas
longtemps aussi c'est le si ça qui va
être plutôt cool mais là tout de suite
on continue du franc je me magne chez
hyper à la bourre jeu rendez vous dans
petite demi heure on part à chantilly
tester le nouveau drone de parrot le
hanafi et là je crois que je suis père à
la bourse chez eux ou la passage des
petites paires dans le deuxième jeu
extrêmement retard pour l'instant le
temps à cannes bien dégueulasse on
risque de se prendre au jeu par la
tronche c'est con pour faire voler un
drone
[Musique]
j'ai peur
oui
[Musique]
pourquoi à chaque fois que je te vois et
une coupe favre non sinon la dernière
fois j'avais déjà une coupe
non jamais c'est pas moi c'est toujours
aux serveurs aussi laisserait donc
forcément j'en profite
c'est inconfortable entre l'a6 sur la
botte de paille mais heureusement qu'on
a un petit coussin
[Musique]
attention quand tu n'as pas encore
planté là si je le flandre avec tout
tout l'espace ya exactement tout le
chemin est ce qu'il ya eu vraiment je
suis j'arrête
j'arrête jean de la fontaine la vidéo je
prends ma retraite
c'est quoi pour toi les trois points
positifs de ce kadhafi a déjà un fils et
une caméra volante qui est ultra
transportable c'est une caméra volante
quatre caches des airs avec du zoom sans
père ces vivres à des braquages quand
les pasteurs du hd là on est sur du luy
hdi du 4k cinéma d'accord ok avec du hdr
vidéo c'est à dire qu'on va étendre la
dynamique de l'image pour récupérer de
l'information des détails dans les zones
sombres et dans les zones surexposées un
drôle qui est intelligent et qui
puissant on va dire que s'il est petit
mais il va atteindre des vitesse
extraordinaire de 55 km heure il assiste
à des vents de 50 km/heure donc c'est
assez impressionnant que les ventes 50
km heure
il garde la stabilité se penche et il
tient la kz way et il vole 25 minutes et
si tu as un des vents qui sont au-delà
de 50 km/heure je peux quand même
essayer de le piloter pour le ramener ou
bien sûr bien sûr c'est qu'il garde le
point fixe jusqu'à 50 km heure et
ensuite il ya toujours le contrôle etc
il vole 25 minutes à 4 km de portée et
en fait on n'a pas besoin d'être un
pilote professionnel pour utiliser un
avis c'est vraiment un jeu d'enfant j'ai
vraiment sortir tu crois je pense que tu
vas te sortir j'ai pas très bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous fais des prises de vues pas
piquée des hannetons latin mode caméra
montée sur le mec en fait j'ai cadré le
mec du coup c'est anvers ouais et j'ai
juste à piloter du coup le drone pour
qu'il fasse un travelling
voilà je tourne autour de vie sans rien
faire
[Musique]
prise en un duo nafi plutôt réussi
franchement le drone est super cool
alors ce qui va chemin en coule c'est
qu'il est très très facile à piloter à
prendre en main il suffit je dirais d'à
peine dix minutes quand on n'est pas
très très bon un peu comme moi pour le
faire décoller comprendre un peu comment
il marche alors l'avis de l'expert ça
dit quoi mais tu vois moi qui suis à la
base un prodigy haye franchement le
clairement celui-là il m'a clancy
il va saisir à beaucoup de personnes je
suis sûre il va très bien marcher parce
que si on fait une super révolution le
zoom tu vois le zoo je pensais que ça
allait pas être si utile que sa voile et
franchement j'ai fait des plans où
j'utilisais tous les joystick en même
temps tu as l'impression d'être un
hélico la caméra hyper facile à
manipuler pour shooter se faire des
plans pour se marier et franchement
c'est hyper facile c'est vrai que c'est
un produit qui est très agréable 25000
d'autonomie suit encore changer la
batterie puis dont j'utilise ça c'est
plutôt cool produit très compact très
réactif plusieurs mois pour ça je vous
dis on va tester plus amplement très
très prochainement parce que pour
l'instant n'a pas encore tout vu du
dessus mais en attendant je trouve que
le produit quand même super cool qu'en
tout cas il séduit bien qui fait pas de
bruit c'est pas bruit là tu vas en
montagne avec ça c'est beaucoup moins
mère dans qu'autre chose l'autonomie
parfaite stabilisation top c'est
franchement parler mais les gens qui ont
leur premier drone je recommande faut
juste faire gaffe avec les y'a pas
détecteur d'obstacles mais franchement
c'est pour avoir confiance à son
pilotage mais mais il est il va entrer
bien c'est un droit aujourd'hui on va en
parler très prochainement on va
continuer un peu de le tester on va le
tester un peu sous toutes les coutures
pour vous dire un petit peu ce que j'en
pense plus concrètement déjà première
prise en main super cool donc rester
connecté vous allez voir on va en parler
en attendant on va continuer à peu la
petite taupe et maintenant je crois
qu'il ya un coup à boire 3 4 madeleine à
manger ça ça va
[Musique]
de retour à paris donc bon plutôt pas
mal au final ce petit drone on va les
tester d'ici quelques temps plus en
détail parce qu à pas mal de choses à
dire dessus
il est là dans le sac anna jean parrot
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va le
tester plus en détail on va voir si au
final il est cool on a testé les
différents modes de pilotage parce qu'il
ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses
à dire je vous invite à faire une seule
chose ça rester connecté à vous abonner
n'en dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez de tout ce que vous avez vu
est-ce qu'il vous paraît cool
est ce que vous pourriez le posséder est
ce qui vous intéresse qu il ya des
drones de dj am est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter par ce drone de
parrot pour marquer tout sans
commentaire merci en tout cas à vous de
m'avoir accompagné aujourd'hui une fête
plus mais je vous dis à très bientôt
ciao
ok